did i hear you say that you feel that
the war on drugs is essentially hopeless
um
you know i i don't know if it's hopeless
but it's not looking good and it's this
thing that we love talking away in the
u.s it's mexico's drug war that sounds
really far
although 50 40 to 50 billion dollars
here come from here
guns come from here the demand comes
from here
so
it's helpless if we don't change it it's
in our hands we have to at least make a
real attempt
and you know and part of the reason to
making this movie is because people
always said oh it's just gangsters
killing gangsters no it affects
everybody edgar songs don't reach
only gangsters actually the majority of
them are great american latino kids who
go to a party scene and
to connect to something that they hear
about
but if we let the bad guys win if
impunity is so vast
then it is hopeless because what one
thing is that's not going to stop and we
got to be real as a demand
and the price and the huge business here
it hasn't stopped for many many years
so right now if you live through it like
i did it feels hopeless in richie's
world in
in juarez yes it feels very hopeless
it's so sad you can't this irony that we
saw again and again sure it broke my
heart it felt like
nobody's paying attention and
everything's obvious
i think you quoted mexico's president
we're living next to the biggest drug
addict in the world which is the us
i mean me and many other journalists
quoted him saying i don't remember the
exact quote of how it's hard to be the
neighbor of the biggest drug addict in
the world and it's true i totally
understand that um
you know if the u.s wasn't there then
with its demand then none of this
would happen including edgar's careers
and song wouldn't be there